Narrator: This is Takayuki,
a cleaning supervisor at
the rail yard in Ayase.
He's worked for Tokyo
Metro for almost 41 years,
and it's his job to make sure
the trains are cleaned thoroughly.
Narrator: The Tokyo Metro system is famous
for being one of the cleanest
subway systems in the world.
It transports an average of
about 6 million people daily,
and maintaining that reputation
takes both an extensive amount
of operational organization
and a ton of manpower.
The cleaning staff's
approach is straightforward
but uncompromising: whatever Tokyo Metro's
millions of daily passengers
touch must be cleaned.
Today, they're cleaning the train cars
at the Ayase rail yard,
which they do every 15 days.
The cleaners take careful measures
to ensure each nook and cranny is cleaned.
Then we'll head to the
Ginza-itchome Station,
located in one of the
busiest shopping areas
in Tokyo, Japan,
where they clean the
station top to bottom.
There are 41 trains on the
Tokyo Metro Chiyoda Line.
The team cleans three
to four trains a day.
Once a train comes into the rail yard,
cleaners start by picking
up any trash they see.
It takes four workers
to clean the exterior.
It's all done by hand, and cleaners start
by hosing it down with water
and then using brushes
to scrub it with soap.
Narrator: If the stain does not come off
with a brush and soap,
then they use a pad to scrub it off.
Next, they rinse off all the soap.
Meanwhile, other staffers
clean the interior.
It takes 10 workers, and they
start at the top of the car
and work their way down to the bottom.
Narrator: The first step
is to clean the area
where advertisements are placed.
Then they clean the luggage
racks, and then the wall area.
They use rags and dusters
to clean each part.
Narrator: Cleaners then tackle the floors
and start by mopping.
They also use sticks to clean crevices
near the entrance of each door.
Twice a year they wax the
floors of each train car.
They remove all the old
wax with a polisher,
and then they let it dry.
Once it's dry, they
apply two coats of wax.
It takes about an hour and a half
from the time the wax is removed
to the time the new wax dries.
Narrator: Altogether, it takes workers
a little over an hour
to clean the trains inside and out.
Once the cleaning is complete,
Takayuki begins his inspection.
Narrator: Once Takayuki
approves the cleaning,
the trains return to service,
ready to transport millions
of passengers all over again.
Inside the Ginza-itchome Station,
Chikako and Kenji work to
clean the station daily.
Narrator: Kazuhiro has been
working for Tokyo Metro
since he was 18.
He got his train license at 20
and drove trains until he was 57.
He leads the team responsible
for the cleaning and security
for this station and a few others.
There are nine Tokyo Metro train lines
and 180 stations that provide service
to the greater Tokyo area.
Narrator: The escalator handrails
are a high-touch surface
within the station,
and Chikako takes extra
care to wipe the belt
with wet washcloths.
She rides the escalators up and down
until they are all clean.
Narrator: Chikako is also responsible
for the dirtiest job of the day,
cleaning the two restrooms
in the Ginza-itchome Station.
The main cleanings happen once a day.
She has been doing this
work for the past 10 years.
Narrator: The first thing Chikako does
is check for any large pieces of trash.
If there are none, she sets up a fan
and leaves it on throughout
the cleaning process.
Efficiency is one of the
key parts of her job,
and the fan allows the
bathroom to dry quickly,
so as not to disrupt any
customers who may need to use it.
Narrator: Chikako sticks
the ozone-machine hose
down the toilet and turns it on.
Then she scrubs each toilet by hand
to make sure it's clean
for the next customer.
She also cleans the walls.
It's important that she's
using the right tools
for each space, so as not
to cross-contaminate areas.
She uses a red dust cloth to clean
areas from the knees down,
which is called the "contamination zone,"
and a green one for "clean zones,"
which are areas above the knees,
such as mirrors and sinks.
Narrator: Chikako is also
responsible for cleaning
the barrier between the
platform and the train doors.
The top part is cleaned daily,
while the lower part
is cleaned once a week.
The staff makes sure the
station platforms and walkways
are clean for customers.
They do cleanings with brooms every day,
but they also use a
machine to clean the floors
twice a month.
The machine works by sprinkling
water onto the floor,
scrubbing with a brush,
and then collecting the
dirty water with a squeegee.
This way, there is no water left behind
and no slippery floors.
Narrator: Kenji also goes around daily
with a shoulder vacuum
and manually vacuums up
any trash and dust he comes across,
especially in hard-to-reach areas.
Narrator: Japan has a
long history with cleaning
and cleanliness that persists today.